I've always been an underdog and I've
never been willing to let anybody tell
me I couldn't do anything that I wanted
to do so
I've always enjoyed taking on challenges
that a lot of other people wanted to run
away from and found a way to do them
even when I was under qualified for them
I grew up in the paternalistic era of
companies I was with a very great
company called IBM and a good piece of
that is as long as you perform you have
a job for life which most people don't
have anymore and you know when you had
babies they would send you a silver
spoon with the baby's name on it and you
have great benefits and it's very safe
and it was all about putting the company
first and moving wherever they told you
to go because as long as you did what
was right for the company everything
worked that is long gone
because most companies don't last a
lifetime anymore and we're in a much
more entrepreneurial global era where
people need to move faster and things
change with much more frequency what's
cool about that is there's a lot more
opportunity but you have to put yourself
first and be in control of your own
destiny because no one company can take
care of you your whole career if you're
a great leader you always put your
people first and understand where
they're intended to go and you help them
grow even if it means leaving your
employee there's not enough talent in
the world
we all have openings we'd like to fill
and I think our job as as executives to
make sure we grow that talent base to
fill those great jobs people would like
to have I think every employee and every
person needs to know where they fit and
what are their unique talents and what
are their unique skills what would they
love to do and they need to take a real
assessment of how capable are they at
this stage of their life in doing what
they'd like to do and then if that
assessment doesn't lead to result that
you're happy with then you need to make
some changes pick up some additional
skills do something you love a little
bit more to be able to get to someplace
that you're in a happier spot